hi this is caitlyn and i'm here at
comic-con and we're here waiting in line
for something called masquerade which
starts tonight at seven forty-five but
right now it's eight in the morning so
i'm here to talk to some people who are
waiting in line can you guys tell me
what masquerade is mascara is like a
giant costume contest where some of the
best costumes I've seen ever in my life
these costumes are worked on for months
at a time and they are taken to the
smallest detail it is so amazing what
you see out there awesome have you seen
math grade before like in previous years
last year was my first year and I was
just a little bit more back than where
we wore and I fell in love with it and I
had to be first in line this year
awesome um so you guys some of you are
in costume here you want to tell me a
little bit about your costume I'm the
green arrow this is acting my halloween
costume I'm like might as well to break
out the cosmic realm account again and
um and you have an interesting homemade
costume can you tell me about it yes i
am the human twister with a slight
variation of the game board and i got
this idea from a website named ready and
I just had to copy it awesome great
ideas come from reddit and how about you
I'm the borrower Arrietty from the new
studio ghibli film of the same name and
my mom actually helped me make it so
exciting so to save my life awesome so
um you guys you're here 12 hours early
you're first in line how do you feel
about this camping out situation like is
it going to be boring fun to wait for
all this time well actually we're doing
this thing where every couple hours we
switch with some friends and we'll come
and flowers and we'll get tickets with
masquerade know we have some games to
amuse us and we're going to hang out
awesome one of the best things about
being in line is you get to kind of sit
back and watch all the people come by
you can see some really awesome costumes
and meets really cool people just by
sitting in line so it's not that bad and
can you tell me some of your favorite
costumes that you've seen either at
masquerade last year or at comic-con
this year it would have to be Princess
Peach and Princess Daisy and drag that
was beautiful especially because I know
that Princess Daisy and that was just a
heartwarming experience anyone else got
a favorite costume that they've seen I
know from the masquerade last year even
though I wasn't here I saw some of this
gets up on YouTube and there was a group
from Mass Effect who had all of these
like crazy prosthetics and like actual
armor it was just so cool i'm really
looking forward to I think they're
coming back this year so I'm looking
forward to it awesome well I wish you
guys all the best of luck I hope that
you are first in the front row and now
you have an awesome time this is caitlin
from comic-con and for more comic con
coverage to check out wired com